would you rather have a high profile job
for no pay or clean sewers for a hundred
thousand dollars a year I think high
profile job with no pay I would prefer
to have the high profile job without
paid I'm cleaning sewage for 100k man
ain't no shame in my game I'm cleaning
sewers there's no question about it I'm
gonna clean the sewers for a hundred
thousand dollars a year I'd rather to
First where you don't want to do the
dangerous Dirty Jobs I know so could
that possibly be why so many women earn
less money than men yep so is that based
on discrimination or based on choice and
choices yeah there you go and by the way
I don't think the women are totally
wrong to want to do that there is
something about the kind of work you're
doing during the day and especially if
you're a lady you don't traditionally
speaking you're not the primary
Breadwinner certain exceptions to that
rule but I don't think it's unreasonable
but it is unreasonable for the feminists
to Screech on and on about a wage Gap
that isn't real bricklayers they're 99
male yeah are we going to equalize that